hello everyone today we are going to be
talking about the idea of a federalized
europe and why i think it's a good idea
my previous video on the subject didn't
really fit my overall content style so
this would be my second take so in this
video we are going to be talking about
the following a quick summary of what a
european federation would look like a
discussion of the most relevant
arguments against it me presenting my
arguments for it in light of what we
heard so far then we take a look at how
feasible all the material is and finally
how i would have the federalization
process play out oh and if my voice
sounds a bit different in this video
that's because i've been a bit sick
lately so let's get to it shall we what
do we understand under a european
federation it's a system of governance
where the local governments transfer
some of their tasks to an overarching
federal body so that those tasks can be
better coordinated on a continental
level and here i'd like to make a note
that federalization doesn't involve
centralizing everything we're not the
soviet union after all as we'll see
later on we're talking about the
strategic centralization of certain
parts of government decisions about
local issues would continue to be made
locally of course unless they contradict
some kind of overarching goal so in
practice in a european federation the
european parliament would be an analogue
for the house of representatives and the
european commission would be an analogue
for the senate of course i'm talking
about the us government here the
president would either be nominated by
the parties or directly elected a
european federation would also involve
common military common foreign affairs
common finances and a common border
security and asylum system among other
things so this is my rough sketch of
what a european federation would look
like so basically certain key aspects of
government would be under common federal
control so would this system be viable
let's find out after a brief word from
today's sponsor skillshare skillshare is
an online learning community with
thousands of classes covering all kinds
of interesting subjects stuff like
interior design or how to properly care
for your houseplants or the essentials
of drawing or how to study for exams or
how to boost your productivity i myself
am doing a class right now about adobe
illustrator by den kulken and nathan
goldman and it's super cool it's very
practical intuitive and easy to follow
and a very important thing for me
personally skillshare curates its
content specifically for learning
meaning there are no ads no hidden
paywalls no bait and switches you are
free to explore absolutely everything
and guess what skillshare is now running
a promotion that means the first 1 000
of my subscribers to click the link in
the description below will get a one
month free trial of skillshare thank you
for checking out skillshare heads like
these help support what i do and now on
with the program before the recording of
this video i asked you to give me your
best arguments against the european
federation i've read lots of great
responses so thank you for taking your
time from all that you've written i've
collected the most relevant and most
often recurring and i would say best
arguments against the federation and now
we're going to address them one by one
now almost all counter arguments involve
some kind of rift within europe which
could make the federation idea
non-viable irreconcilable differences as
they say but are they the first argument
is the conservative versus progressive
divide for example sweden is a heaven of
progressivism while poland is the
european taliban and the argument of
course is that the ideological rift
between the conservative and progressive
parts of europe is so large that the
european federation would be non-viable
because of that now i think the main
issue with this argument is that it
views countries as these homogenous
blocs for example even poland has a huge
conservative versus progressive divide
polish cities are progressive while the
polish countryside is conservative that
being said even the most conservative
european countries are slowly becoming
more and more progressive according to
this pew research data young people are
far more accepting of lgbt rights for
example than older people and this is
the case in every eastern european
country that we would consider
conservative okay but what about the
political forces of these countries
hungary and poland for example are led
by ultra-conservative far-right
governments well both in poland and
hungary if you add up the conservative
and the progressive forces they are
pretty much neck and neck and in hungary
for example all those huge percentage
numbers that fides victor orban's party
produced are essentially just one-third
of the population two-thirds being
opposition or just apolitical in other
words this conservative versus
progressive divide is not that deep and
with time it will only get smaller so i
don't think the conservative progressive
divide would be such a big problem i
mean we already have it and things
aren't falling apart really let's move
on to another frequent argument namely
the rich board divide within europe and
the gist of this argument is that the
great wealth differences between
countries or in this case regions would
lead to all kinds of distortions
economic there is such as internal mass
migration poorer regions getting
abandoned etc now of course there are
significant economic differences between
european countries but this is something
that a federalized europe could actually
help solve in my opinion for example a
federal anti-corruption court could
oversee the spending of cohesion funds
sort of like olaf right now but on
steroids less corruption on the poorer
ends would definitely help with the
economic situation also a federal
healthcare budget would do wonders to
poorer member states ideally there
should be a federal minimum wage for
healthcare workers paid from the central
budget for example in every country a
doctor's minimum gross salary should be
say 2 000 euros and nurses 1400. now
this wouldn't really affect western
countries where salaries are already
much higher but it would make all the
difference in countries like bulgaria
romania or hungary or even poland this
way we could solve the problem of
healthcare workers migrating to the west
for better pay causing severe personal
shortages back home once again the
salaries would not need to be equal
across the board but high enough to
prevent public service workers from
leaving their home country and mass i
would do the same thing with education
actually have a federal minimum teacher
salary and bring schools up to a certain
quality standard a strong economy begins
with a strong well-educated workforce as
they say so i think a european
federation would actually be a great
solution to earth inequality because it
could shift resources much more
efficiently and most importantly it
could also check the correct spending of
those resources and there is a mechanism
for checking already called the european
prosecutor's office from which member
states can opt out freely including
hungary i wonder why that is boy sure
sounds like resisting european
integration is just a cover for
politicians to preserve their power and
to keep up their domestic corruption
schemes without anyone able to stop them
speaking of which let us now talk about
the national sovereignty argument now
national sovereignty in the face of
european integration is a great lie that
many still believe leaders like orban
tell people that more european
integration will take power away from
them them as in the people in reality if
we federalized everything tomorrow the
people would still have democratic
control over their decision makers
whether local or federal the only
tangible difference would be that people
like orban could no longer reign supreme
within their borders the local political
ruling class would actually have some
oversight and so national sovereignty is
a neat trithorical trick used by
politicians to make people believe that
the local politicians losing some power
is equivalent to the electorate losing
power now this would be true if the
political power was transferred to a
dictatorship but in this case we are
only transferring some functions from a
local democratic government to a central
democratic government now the national
sovereignty argument is a form of
so-called eu bashing which is the
political equivalent of reactionary
ntsjw content which can be summarized as
follows no real arguments just vague
gesturing against the imagined hypocrisy
and this neat definition comes from wash
as far as i can tell you'll find the
link to his channel in the description
but the thing about eu bashing is that
it's kinda getting old people aren't so
quick to jump on the bandwagon and are
increasingly seeing it for what it is a
cheap political trick to divert
attention from domestic problems so as
we can see the national sovereignty
argument doesn't really hold up the next
big argument is about cultural
differences namely that european
cultures are simply too different to
work together on such a high level so
the federalization of europe is based on
a very important realization let me
explain i was born in hungary and i have
a bunch of relatives in the countryside
who live in villages in the east when i
visit them i find that i have nothing in
common with them or the people around
them and we have vastly different ideas
about virtually everything we eat
different food we enjoy different
entertainment we consume different media
we definitely have different drinking
habits we have different mannerisms the
list goes on basically the hungarian
language is the only thing we have in
common in contrast when i studied for a
year in germany on my erasmus
scholarship i got to meet people like me
young college age middle class with who
i had a lot in common and those people
were from all over europe north and
south east and west almost every
european country was represented there
and virtually the only tangible
difference between us was our native
languages but we all spoke english so by
virtue of all of us there being highly
educated middle class young adults i had
much more in common with people from
northern finland southern spain or even
eastern russia than with my hungarian
relatives living a few hours away and
mind you many of those hungarian
relatives are the same age as i so this
cultural differences argument doesn't
really add up it's just simply outdated
it would have made some sense in the
1950s or 60s but ever since then the
world has become much more
interconnected alright so the next
argument we're going to be looking at is
language namely that europe has no real
common language and people being unable
to communicate with each other would
lead to chaos or you know there's just
not enough linguistic cohesion for a
european federation now this argument is
a big one however it also suffers from
the same problem as the cultural
argument namely that it's becoming more
and more outdated now this argument
would have been fair a few decades ago
but in our current day and age english
is very quickly becoming the common
language of europe sorry friends even in
the most english illiterate countries a
good fifth of the population speaks it
already and with the internet and our
increasingly global culture these
percentages will only go up the common
administrative language inside a
european federation would of course be
english in fact in the current european
union it already pretty much is sorry
friends again this means that a federal
european government would not be
affected by a language barrier and i
would make sure by making english
courses part of public sector employment
the government pays for a private
teacher or something to come by and
teach for a few hours each week for free
as part of the employee's work time and
in practice this would mean that every
government office would have all forms
and all services available in the local
language plus in english and so this
leaves us with the general populace
outside of the public sphere now would
there be a linguistic problem i don't
think so people already live in areas
where they can access everything in
their own native languages and this
would be the same under european
federation and there could only be
problems if people would want to leave
those areas and go to other areas where
there's another language but the people
who do move around are usually the ones
who already speak foreign languages here
in germany for example i've met a lot of
fellow hungarians who work here they all
speak german or english and they have no
linguistic issues whatsoever now as an
important side note some industries at
this point do not really require
knowledge of the local language for a
lot of occupations like finance i.t or
even some blue-collar jobs like trucking
english is often enough so with all this
being said i don't think the federal
europe idea would topple over because of
language it could become a problem here
and there but it could still be handled
through policy at the end of the day the
most important thing is that the
government has a common language which
at this point it pretty much does so
this problem has really been solved by
the circumstances i would say and so i'm
not especially worried about it alright
so let's move on to the ultimate
argument the biggest one namely european
states differing geopolitical interests
now this right here is the most
important argument of them all and to
properly address it i'll be rolling it
into why i think a european federation
is absolutely necessary alright so why
do i think that a european federation is
absolutely necessary at the end of the
day it all comes down to more efficient
use of resources both tangible and
non-tangible for example a federal
europe should have a unified military
instead of dozens of smaller armies
operating separately let's have a common
command structure a unified european
military would be much more effective i
much more stronger for the same amount
of money and with an active war
currently ongoing on european soil
meaning the war in donbass i think it's
an absolute necessity another hugely
important aspect is common finances a
unified tax policy to end tax havens
looking at you ireland and things like
more efficient control over budget
spending it's much easier to track
corruption it turns out if certain
states can't just opt out of the
anti-corruption measure in practice
common finances would mean the effort
mentioned plus a federal budget for
federal issues and local budgets for
local issues also something else that's
also very important is a common defense
force and asylum system if europe had a
well-organized network of refugee camps
and a unified border force the 2015
refugee crisis would not have been so
severe i believe and thus the consequent
far-right resurgence wouldn't have
happened it was pretty amazing to see
how quickly the eu's refugee system
folded back in the day mostly because
individual countries started pushing the
refugees onto each other instead of
working together there was a quota
system developed to help distribute some
refugees among member states but four
outlet countries of course started
screaming about it immediately hungary
for example ended up suffering a
complete national mental breakdown over
it for having to house 1294
migrants and only until their silo
applications are processed oh and here
by hungary i mean of course the
hungarian government and its supporters
speaking of the refugee crisis a unified
federal police could track crime across
borders more efficiently including
terrorism a federal secret service could
process all the intel much better
instead of having dozens of small secret
services operating parallel to each
other so we won't have things like the
hungarian secret service not noticing
salah abdeslam the patala massacres
organizer buying 200 000 sim cards in
budapest yes that actually happened i
even have a video about it feel free to
check it out alright so i promised i
would get to the geopolitical interests
argument so here it is under my
community post a lot of you have
correctly identified this as a problem
however i'll be approaching this issue
from the other way around europe is
indeed full of clashing geopolitical
interests for example poland is
staunchly anti-russian while hungary's
viktor orban has a vip entry guard into
putin's pants germany is also quite
ambivalent on the russia question since
its industry depends on russian gas most
eu member states are against china or
view it as a rival while viktor orban
openly collaborates with them a united
european geopolitical front i believe is
the most important thing to have right
now our neighbor russia though on the
decline is an increasingly oppressive
oil monarchy with nuclear weapons one
that currently engages in active warfare
on european soil china is a totalitarian
tech dystopia and the new global
superpower india is an upcoming
superpower i guess they couldn't do it
by 2020 but it's coming still even if
russia collapsed tomorrow and the war in
donbass ended that still leaves us with
china and india as rivals as they grow
stronger i don't think european
countries will be able to do anything
against their influence unless they
present a unified front people don't
really realize the insane power
potential these countries have for the
sake of perspective slovenia has a
population of 2 million hungary 10
million germany 83 million meanwhile
india has 1
366 million and china 1
398 million now of course number of
people is not the end-all beo but they
serve as a good basis for future power
and people are resources after all human
resources alone european countries are
just figures on the chessboard of global
powers together they can become a global
power themselves gone are the times when
the uk germany or france alone could be
a significant force on the global stage
we are now entering a new age of global
powers so far europe could serve the
waves of u.s hegemony but new players
are coming to the table and because of
this a united european front is
necessary now i can see why people would
find the idea of a european federation
strange scary or even outright
impossible it's actually natural to feel
that way ahead of every major paradigm
shift in governance i imagine people
must have felt the same way about the
first european nation state back in the
day how it's impossible for a country to
last outside of vatican influence how
henry viii is too much of an idealist
how the anglican church will tear
england apart and so on but in the end
it worked out pretty okay until june
2016 that is alright so now all of you
should have a much better idea about how
a federal europe would look like but
what are the chances for the emergence
of a federal europe well they're pretty
good i must say currently support for
the eu is pretty much green or i should
say blue across the board also crucially
most people in most european countries
want more decisions to be taken on the
eu level it seems like people would
support a reasonable redelegation of
power to eu institutions and i think a
common foreign policy would be such a
measure and also a common military a
common fiscal policy and common
non-optional anti-corruption
institutions among other things and once
again none of this is science fiction
most people in most european countries
trust all major european institutions
the eu's trust rating is finally
recovering after the 2008-2009 economic
crisis and in recent years kovit 19 has
only shown people the need for even
closer european integration common eu
vaccine procurement was generally a
success despite the rough start the idea
was that european countries together
have much much more leverage than alone
when negotiating with pharma companies
and well you know duh alright so let us
now move on to the last section namely
how i would have the federalization
process play out one word incrementally
the measures i mentioned would of course
take years upwards to a decade to
implement i don't want to do any of
these things just overnight i want to
make a plan for deeper integration start
executing it in phases and correct the
course if something doesn't seem to be
working out and i do think it will be
extremely important to sell this idea to
people gradually now normally i don't
think an idea like this would need to be
sold since it has objective tangible
benefits that any reasonable person
would want the problem as always is the
reactionary counter campaign that will
inevitably follow or disinformation
propaganda to use a non-pc term you know
the uk's eu membership had tangible
objective benefits that any reasonable
person would want and oh boy how's that
brexit thing working out so far huh so
you know i'd like to congratulate all
the leave campaigners as they have shown
mindless gesturing against imaging
hypocrisy is a very effective political
tool the entire leaf campaign was built
on this and to their dismay they
actually succeeded their most iconic
slogan in fact was a complete lie and
people need to be equipped against this
the disinformation that is the source of
which nowadays is an increasingly
reactionary modern conservatism oh and
i'll have to make a video about this
won't i so anyway as we've seen the
federalization of europe wouldn't be the
founding of the galactic empire or
something it would be a set of mostly
bureaucratic processes building upon
what has already been done so far which
will affect our local political ruling
classes first and foremost and i do
believe people will only benefit from
this oh and also when the next capital
riot actually succeeds the free world
would need to be led by someone else so
thank you for watching i hope you
enjoyed this reworked take on the
european federation and thank you once
again for all your responses in my
community section don't forget to like
and subscribe and i'll be seeing you
next time